welcome to beyond corporate a bottle
where we explore journeys into the world
of context where access and zero trust
networks probably got a list of
employees living in Active Directory or
some single sign-on or LDAP equivalent
in order to enforce your security
policies and take advantage of context
to where access you'll need to create
smarter fine-grained controls Google's
tools need to know who's asking for
access so we'll need to get that
identity information into Google somehow
the easy way and what we do at Google is
to use G suite and then all your
identities already live in Google cloud
if you want some extra work though you
can always sync your identities from
your system to Google let's look at both
options for G suite companies your
identity already lives on Google cloud
so Google cloud platform can see all the
users and groups you've set up quick and
easy if you're an Active Directory or
open SSO LDAP etc then Google's cloud
directory sync tool lets you quickly
pull your identity information into
Google identity enabling you to make
cloud access decisions based on group
memberships and user lists that you
already have that's key to context to
where access who you are matters and
it's more important than where you are
without the whom we can't make a good
decision about whether or not a given
request should be granted our migration
to this beyond Corp inspired model
requires knowledge about identity for
each request that's how identity aware a
proxy can make its person based
decisions let's say you decide your
first order of business is to lock down
your financial tools to just folks in
finance to reduce the chance of Revenue
data leaking your finance web
applications can be protected by
identity aware proxy using the identity
groups you brought into Google earlier
it's quick and easy to restrict your
payroll app to only people in the
finance group with just a few clicks
this system also lets you automate
updating access when people change roles
if I used to work in finance then move
over to legal my payroll management
access should disappear as soon as my
groups are updated within Google
identity IEP will enforce the current
policies based on my new membership
give it a try with one of the various
quick starts for IEP or the guide for
cloud directory sync linked below to get
more detail check out my blog post for
step-by-step instructions and subscribe
to get more videos on context-aware
access when it comes to protecting your
company keep your data yours
[Music]